Hãy chúng ta bác khi tựa phía văn cuối xa trong ngày 1 tảng hình xấu của vực trung dù và đồng bằng bác bộ vẫn duy trì nắng nắm,
mới nhé đậu phụ biến từ bà ngâm đến bác bi bại đủ xe.
Tuy nhiên, tự chưa to với và đêm cùng ngày không khi lại sẽ chàng xuống, nền sẽ nhắc thấp và người trên dự dầu.
Cú vực tế bác bộ cùng phía bác cắt đình phụ thậu và tuyên quan được dự báo có 1 tò từ năm 1 đi một trang Millimet,
có nơi trên 2 trang Millimet. Cái điểm phương khác ở bác bộ cùng thêm ngoái và người an, có lượng mơ phụ biến từ 2 mơ,
đến năm 1 mơ, cũng bộ chi một trang Millimet. Giò anh ngồi của không khi lại,
như độ tại thủ đô được dự báo 3 mạch trong những ngày đầu tưởng tới,
xuống không từ 2 năm đến 2 mơ, tại các vùng đối cao như 3 mơ, như độ có thể giảm mất từ 1 xấu đến 1 tảng độ.
Trong khi đó, nắng nắm vẫn tiếp sĩnh thành nhiều địa phương miền chung,
với như độ phụ biến từ bác ngâm đến 3 mơ, con nơi trên 3 mơ.
Đến ngày 1 mơ thằng xấu độ nắng dự dộ tại cú bực này các bạn chấm giết.
Trong người cơ mơ lớn, bán chỉ đạo phòng thủ dân sự cua ra đã đề nghị cái địa phương bác bộ,
thành ngoá phần người an, chủ động theo dõi dịch biến thời tiết, ra soát các khu bật con người cơ luo quay xà lở đất,
sẵn sàng chình khai các phương an, bó đảm ẵn tòm chương liên dân và sẵn thiệu thiết thại giò thiên tay thế ra.